What If Luffy Was Never Born In One Piece?
What would have happened to all the straw
hats?
And who would have become pirate king in his
stead?
I spent accidentally spent an entire day I
was supposed to be working, playing through
all the possible scenarios and discovered
one time line that seemed the most likely
to me.
And the results were so fascinating and tragic,
that i thought: why not turn this into a video!
Everything I’ll discuss will be based on
the manga and I swear, you will not be able
to guess who actually will be crowned pirate
king in Luffy’s stead in the end.
So let’s start with Luffy’s childhood
years.
If Dragon never got to find Luffy’s mysterious
mother and make the future pirate king, quite
a few things change in the years before the
main story line, but not quite as much as
you might think.
For example, Garp will still be on Dawn Island,
looking after Roger’s son Ace.
Ace will still meet Sabo, as he did without
Luffy anyways and both of them will train
together, fight together and share Sake cups
to become brothers.
Trying to sail away, Sabo’s ship still gets
sunk by the celestial Dragons and he is once
again rescued and taken in by Dragon.
Maybe in this timeline he realized that having
a kid you never visit, is not a great idea.
The biggest change to the story of course,
are the events that happen in chapter 1: Shanks
still arrives in Fusha village, but never
gets to meet Luffy, who as a result doesn’t
eat the Gomu slash Nika fruit and thus never
becomes Joy Boy.
So here we have to make our first speculation,
that’s gonna have a major impact on how
this all plays out: What would have happened
with this legendary fruit instead?
And at this point I’m gonna make an assumption
that I believe is very likely to be true,
but not yet 100% confirmed in the story.
If you have seen more of my content, you will
know, that I firmly believe that originally
Shanks was planning to give the Nika fruit
to none other than Ace, before Luffy simply
gobbled it down and made himself the new chosen
one.
Let me explain.
Shanks clearly knew about the importance of
the Nika fruit.
The government tried to get their hands on
it for centuries and once they finally did,
Shanks was there to take it away from them.
We also know that Roger found out about Joy
Boy and his prophezised return on Laugh Tale.
He made sure to create the big pirate era
to draw out the right person and make sure
he would return.
We know that he placed his former mate Crocus
at the entrance of the grand line to wait
for the right person to come.
Crocus literally says ‘you might be the
one we have been waiting for Roger’ when
he meets Luffy.
And his right hand man Rayleigh is stationed
on Amazon Lily, the choke point you have to
pass in order to reach the new world.
Rayleigh knew about Luffy from Shanks and
spent 2 years training Luffy to prepare him
for the second half of his journey.
When Luffy awakens his devil fruit, zunesha
takes his heartbeat as the sign of Joy Boy’s
return.
So I think it’s very likely that Shanks’
task as the crew member that Roger entrusted
his straw hat to, was to find the right person
to eat this fruit and guide his way to becoming
pirate king.
Now, as we know, that is Luffy.
But he ate the fruit by accident, and we also
know that Roger was eager to have a son before
he died, which is Ace, a guaranteed member
of the D clan, just like Luffy.
So I think, that Shanks went to Dawn Island
not on a fluke, but to give this legendary
devil fruit to Ace, the son of his former
captain and make him the next joy boy.
And so if Luffy was never born, I believe
that exactly this would have happened.
Shanks finds Ace and gives him the Nika fruit.
He might even sacrifice his arm once again,
to make sure that Ace would try to become
a great pirate too.
After that however, I think that things would
stay quite similar.
Shanks makes sure to watch over Ace from afar,
but lets him do his own thing.
As a result, Ace becomes a pirate, becomes
captain of the spade pirates, gets defeated
by Whitebeard and joins his crew.
Very much to the displeasure of Shanks, Rayleigh
and co, as Whitebeard doesn’t have any interest
in going to Laugh Tale, but also is too powerful
to be convinced otherwise, although not for
a lack of trying.
So Ace becomes a strong pirate and commander
under Whitebeard, only that he has Rubber
powers instead of fire powers.
But he’s quite smart as we know and figures
out how to use his fruit effectively.
Which now brings us to the current timeline
and the straw hats.
If Luffy was never born, and never set out
to sea to gather his crew, what would have
happened to each of them?
As you’ll realize very quickly, there is
a reason why Luffy is the protagonist.
Without him, things get quite dark.
We start the east blue saga by going to Alvida’s
ship, where Luffy pops out of a barrel at
the beginning of the story to save Koby.
This time around however, there is nothing
in this barrel.
Koby will for the rest of his life be forced
to work the deck on the pirate’s ship.
He will never be inspired to follow his impossible
looking dream of becoming a marine admiral.
As a result, neither he nor luffy make it
to Morgan’s Marine base, where Zoro is being
starved by Helmeppo.
Without Luffy to rescue him, Zoro’s realizes
that Helmeppo never meant to stand by his
word to release him after 30 days without
food.
instead Zoro, who at this point is too weak
to free himself, simply starves to death in
a horrifying and tragic manner.
The pitiful end of the future strongest swordsman
in the world.
Mihawk never even learns his name.
In Orange Town, Buggy manages to reach the
grand line, but is soon captured by the marines
anyways.
Nami has barely managed to outwit Buggy and
escape him, even without Luffy’s help.
On Syrup village, Kuro’s 3 year plan to
plunder the island is finally complete.
Despite Usopp’s warnings of pirates, no
one in the village believes him.
Usopp wants to be brave and fight, but is
paralyzed by fear and he runs away.
Ultimately he and all the other villagers
are slaughtered by Kuro’s men, while his
dad is having a party with Shanks somewhere
in the New World.
. He will never become a brave warrior of
the sea.
The only way to save Usopp is by subscribing
right now.
At the Baratie, things go a bit differently.
While Luffy isn’t there to save the Baratie
from Don Krieg, when you think about it, Krieg
only survives Mihawk chasing after them because
Mihawk’s becomes more interested in Zoro
and his challenge.
With Zoro still slowly wasting away in the
afternoon sun of Morgan’s base, Mihawk simply
finishes what he has come for all the way
from the grand line.
Sink the rest of Krieg’s ship.
So instead of the Baratie sinking, Mihawk
eats Krieg for lunch and then has a nice dinner
with some good wine at the Baratie.
Sanji keeps working there happily as a cook
for 2 more years, until a mafia boss shows
up at the restaurant.
He tells Sanji that he is going to be married,
unless he wants all of the cooks on the ship
to die.
Sanji complies and is taken to Whole Cake
Island.
Here he is humiliated by his family, before
Big Mom’s crew murders the entire family
at the wedding and takes Germa’s technology.
Meanwhile, Nami’s village is never freed
from Arlong’s rule.
His men come to confiscate all the money she
has saved up so far.
Despite her despair, she can’t let her people
down, so she keeps drawing more and more maps
for Arlong, locked in her tiny room inside
his castle.
At this point, Luffy and his crew enter the
Grandline and are starting to make a name
for themselves as Rookies.
Without Luffy however, Crocus has met Ace,
but wasn’t of any real help, as he was with
Whitebeard.
Laboon keeps smashing his head against the
red line until he finally succumbs to his
injuries.
Brook will never be able to keep his promise
with the whale.
On Drum island, Chopper lives his life with
Kureha, scared and unsure about where he belongs
in this world as a monster and outcast.
When Wapol returns to the country, he kicks
him and Kureha out of the castle and both
of them have to live under his tyranny.
Ace still comes to Drum however, looking for
Blackbeard, who has taken the Yami Yami no
mi and betrayed the crew.
In the meantime, Crocodile is able to overthrow
Alabasta without any major issues.
He kills the king and vivi and finds the secret
chamber.
Here, either Robin refuses to tell him about
Pluton and is killed, or she does tell him
the truth: That Pluton is located under the
country of Wano in the new world, under the
control of Kaido.
Crocodile manages to build his power from
here much faster than if he had been caught
and brought to Impel Down.
He prepares a plan to take on Kaido.
Robin meanwhile Robin goes her own separate
path, but is sooner or later captured by the
agents of CP9 or CP0 and brought to Impel
Down as well.
The last scholar of Ohara.
She will never find out that Saul is still
alive, or that the library of ohara has been
saved.
Instead she fully vanishes into the darkness
of her heart and the depths of level 6 in
Impel Down.
Skypea is actually quite interesting.
Without Luffy’s interference, Enel is God
for a while longer, before making his way
to the moon anyways, this time accompanied
by his men.
Also Bellamy gets to keep all his teeth.
On Water seven, Franky is simply living his
delinquent life as head of the Franky family.
At some point, Lucci and the other CP9 agents
find out that he has the plans for Pluton.
Franky heroically burns the plans in front
of Lucci’s eyes, but is executed by the
furious agent, who has turned into a giant
Leopard.
Meanwhile Shanks is once again meeting with
Whitebeard.
He is here to talk about Blackbeard and urges
Newgate to call Ace back.
He is way too important to die.
In the florian triangle, Brook spends the
next year alone in the dark without his shadow.
Moria grows his Zombie army and finds a suitable
shadow for Oars.
He takes thriller bark to the new world and
attacks Wano once again, convinced he can
win.
However, even with Oar’s reanimated Corpse,
he can’t stand up to the might of the beast
pirates.
While he is able to enter the country and
lay siege to the flower capital, once Orochi
calls for help, Kaido and the all stars swoop
in and ultimately defeat his army in less
than 10 minutes.
Brook’s shadow is released.
He goes on to become a rock start.
Meanwhile, Onimaru buries Ryuma’s corpse
back at his grave and lies Shisui on top.
The tragedy on Sabaody Archapelago never happens.
A bunch of rookies, known as the worst generation
meet here and then move on to the new world.
Camie isn’t saved by Rayleigh and is sold
to Carlos.
Rayleigh is seeing Whitebeard to urge him
that Ace as the next Joy Boy, has to become
pirate king.
Whitebeard reveals, that he was planning to
make Ace his successor all along.
That Roger had told him the truth about the
D Clan and his son, and that he simply had
wanted to make sure Ace is ready.
But it’s too late.
Ace confronts Blackbeard and is captured and
taken to Impel Down.
Jinbei and Ivankov never escape the prison
until much later, when Morley comes for them.
Jinbei becomes a revolutionary.
And so, even without Luffy, the war at Marineford
still happens.
Blackbeard tries to sneak into Impel Down
to get the level 6 prisoners for his crew.
But without Luffy’s uprising and Shiriyu
being released to stop them, Magellan wipes
out the entire crew.
This time there is no antidote.
Blackbeard had made one gamble too much and
lost to fate.
The most likely candidate for pirate king
has died without anyone even realizing it.
Meanwhile, at Marineford, the war is about
to begin, but this time things are very different.
Rayleigh and most of the remaining Roger pirates
have come to fight side by side with Whitebeard
to free Joy Boy, the one hope to change the
world, that they have been working towards
so carefully for 20 years.
Shanks and his crew also join the war right
from the start.
It’s all or nothing.
At first, the two Yonko crews seem to have
the upper hand, easily breaching the first
few lines of defenses.
Mihawk has refused to come and fight against
his friend.
However suddenly the sky blackens as a gigantic
azure dragon appears over the navy headquartes
and a fleet of ships appears on the horizon.
Because Shanks never went to stop him, Kaido
has decided to join the war and make it the
biggest battle the world has ever seen.
He wants to draw out joy boy.
And now we have 3 parties fighting the war.
Sengoku orders Ace to be executed right now.
Shanks uses his Haki to temporarily knock
out almost every single person on the battlefield,
except the other 2 Yonko, Rayleigh, the admirals
and sengoku and garp.
Kaido asks Shanks if he could be Joy boy,
to which Shanks yells that it’s Ace not
him.
Kaido is shocked by this, but it’s too late.
Akainu has returned to the execution platform
and Ace dies the same way he did last time,
this time not able to give his life for his
little brother.
The entire battlefield falls into an eerie
silence.
Then suddenly Ace begins to melt, as a drum
starts to play.
Ace, just like Luffy has died and thus awakened
his legendary devil fruit.
Joy Boy has returned.
With an awakened ace, who already is quite
a lot older and stronger than Luffy was at
this point, the tide of the battle quickly
turns.
Kaido has decided to join their side for now.
He had been waiting for Joy Boy’s return
his entire life.
However as the marines and Shichibukai are
about to be defeated, a dark shadow falls
on the island.
Something is above the clouds.
Then a bright light, like the sun.
And Marineford island never existed.
Imu and the Gorosei have decided to sacrifice
their strongest fighters in order to take
out 3 Yonkos and Joy Boy in one foul swoop.
In the aftermath of the war, the last standing
Yonko is now Big Mom, who collects Shank’s
and Kaido’s Road Poneglyphs and takes over
Wano ann Elbaf.
With Orochi by her side, 2 years later, she
learns the location of Zou from Kanjuro and
takes the last poneglyph as well.
Using Pudding’s abilities she is able to
decipher the hidden location of Laugh Tale
and is crowned QUeen of the pirates.
However, as she reads Joy Boy’s words, she
realizes that she can’t change the world
without the Nika Fruit.
When you think about it, it’s really crazy
how important Wano is even in a world without
Luffy.
And there are just so many things we just
learned in this one arc.
If you want a one hour plus breakdown of Wano
and why it was so controversial, you can watch
that right here.